CBS News investigation has uncovered an
alleged lack of action by one of the
most powerful Catholic Church leaders in
handling sex abuse claims Cardinal
Daniel DiNardo has been the archbishop
of Galveston Houston since 2006 and his
president of the US Conference of
Catholic Bishops last week he presided
over around 300 bishops in Baltimore to
address the church's sex abuse crisis
Niki batiste tracked him down oh boy did
she in Baltimore to ask him about the
claims Nicki good morning good morning
this summer a priest Cardinal DiNardo
had promoted was arrested for allegedly
molesting two children in the late 1990s
Cardinal DiNardo vowed by January to
release a list of all the priests in
Houston who have been in the churches
judgment credibly accused of sexually
abusing a child but we spoke with
victims who say DiNardo still has their
abusers in active ministry i shrank I
was like I'm not here I left my body
John Labonte who is speaking out for the
first time says the Cardinal DiNardo has
allowed this priest father John Keller
to continue presiding over one of the
largest Catholic churches in Houston
Labonte says Keller molested him when he
was 16 years old at your lowest point
what were you feeling I didn't want to
be around you I was just consumed my
pain Labonte brought his allegations to
the archdiocese in 2002 he says he told
them that father Keller plied him with
alcohol and fondled him in his bed on an
overnight trip well I mean it you know
right here where it says you know acted
very inappropriate a letter from the
archdiocese says that father Keller
acknowledged holding Labonte in a manner
inappropriate for a priest but denies
any sexual intent ultimately the church
could not conclude that what happened
constituted sexual abuse the church
promise to put father Keller into
therapy and Cardinal DiNardo has kept
him in active ministry
at Prince of Peace church where our CBS
news cameras captured Cardinal DiNardo
visiting recently just last week we saw
Cardinal DiNardo in father John Keller's
Church what does that tell you if he
knows then he's a liar and it makes me
angry
we poured over court records and turns
up graphic allegations against a second
active priest in Houston in a sworn
affidavit a victim accused father
Terrence Brinkman of wearing his priests
collar as he sodomized me as a
twelve-year-old in the 1970s
attorneys for Cardinal de Nardo's
Archdiocese argued that the statute of
limitations had passed and the case was
thrown out of court today Father
Brinkman is a priest at st. John the
Evangelist
in a statement Father Brinkman denied
any involvement saying I cannot tell you
that these events did not take place but
I was not the person who did them to him
and the archdiocese says the victim
provided a physical description that
does not match father Brinkman all I
want for them to say was yes he did
and I believe you alodia Flores along
with her siblings Monica and Raymond
were all molested by another priest in
Houston Father Lawrence Peguero
who died in 2000 after they sued the
archdiocese they met personally with
Cardinal DiNardo we were invited to meet
with him that our attorney felt this
would be maybe closure an opportunity to
receive an apology how would you
describe his demeanor Raymond thank you
Cardinal DiNardo in a statement told us
that he apologized during the meeting
did any of you get an apology from
Cardinal dinner no no no no
we spent three months asking for a
formal interview with Cardinal DiNardo
he never made himself available so we
caught up with him in the hallway during
the conference of the US bishops in
Baltimore last week are you aware that
you have two priests with credible
sexual abuse allegations currently in
active ministry in your diocese
it depends what names you're talking
about
father John Keller and Reverend Terrance
not a credible one I do as never was
never credible are those the two names
for me to be on your list of
while working on the list
did the name John Labonte yes I would
prefer to do this at another time we've
been requesting we'd love to sit down
I did another time yeah what would you
say to father Keller today come clean
step up what would you say to Cardinal
DiNardo don't leave any stones unturned
put effort into it fix the problem CBS
News has spoken with more than 20 people
with knowledge of allegations made
against priests and the Archdiocese of
Galveston Houston not one has been
contacted by church authorities or
investigators in a statement to CBS News
Cardinal DiNardo said that the church
has made important strides in addressing
this evil but he went on saying we can
and will do better well he seems
surprised to see you even though you've
been reaching out for an interview and
sit down with him what comes next for
Cardinal DiNardo
the Justice Department seems to have a
federal investigation underway and
Cardinal DiNardo says the church will
fully cooperate yeah well him saying oh
it depends on which name is on that list
so that's not credible it's not the
answer we were hoping for be interesting
to see that list come January no a
nikkie when he said you want prefer to
do this 'even other time he said well
we've been asking and here we are we've
been asking for three months I know I
know you have and that ask is still out
there
Nicky thank you